Hello everyone! Today, we will explain
how to get rid of too many dimensions.
Especially, after in the last video
we have learnt that they can be
often a curse, so yes, in a sense,
today we learn how to lift curses.
There are many methods for
dimensionality reduction,
like PCA, ICA, BBA, Funny-yay,…
Ok, I messed up. Here, again:
PCA, ICA, NMF, LDA, IDA, t-SNE,
UMAP, Autoencoders and so on.
And all are awesome, coming with
their own solutions and tricks.
But today, we will discuss
the basics by example of PCA,
which stands for Principal Component Analysis.
In a nutshell: PCA uses some heuristics
to find the most important directions
in the data, then it can discard
the most unimportant parts,
in order to achieve the desired
dimensionality of the target space.
If the data would be 2-dimensional, we
could even visualize it easily, like this.
Looking at the data, clearly there are
more important dimensions than others.
In this direction, the spread is not that big and
if we would clamp all points onto one line,
we would not lose that much information.
We would only lose a lot of information,
if we would get rid of the
other direction of the spread,
because there the spread is much bigger and
helps as a lot to differentiate the points.
So the main idea of the PCA algorithm is
to keep the directions of the biggest spread
and throw away the rest until we reach
the desired number of dimensions, D prime.
But how to do that? With math, of course,
but first let’s think about this intuitively:
What if we would approximate
our data with an ellipse,
basically a 2dimensional Gaussian and
find out the main axes of the ellipse?
These axes, which are called
"principal components" are
exactly the directions we are looking for.
We can keep the most important principal
components and throw away the other ones!
But intuition does not compute
stuff for us, math does.
So let’s see how we could do this
mathematically, by setting up the PCA algorithm:
First, let’s suppose we have our
data X which is a matrix with
rows containing all our data points. The columns
contain the features of these data points.
Then, we want to centralize our data, meaning
that the mean of all points should be 0.
How to do that?
By taking the data
and subtracting it’s mean. Done.
After this simple transformation,
we are ready to go on.
We want to find the biggest
spread or variance of the data,
because that is the informative part,
the part most unpredictable of the data.
For that, we compute the
scatter matrix of the data,
defined by this formula. And remember,
we have already subtracted the mean,
this is the reason why the formula for the
scatter matrix is not more complicated.
But what is this thing, the scatter matrix?
We remember that our data X is composed
of rows of D-dimensional vectors.
If we take one of these rows, transpose it and
do the multiplication, we get a DxD matrix.
And of course, we sum this
over all data samples i.
Why have we done this? In order to be
able to apply our intuition, remember? We
wanted to compute the main axes of the ellipse.
Well, it turns out that these
directions of the main axes are
actually the eigenvectors of this scatter matrix.
And each eigenvector, has a so-called eigenvalue,
which captures the importance of the
eigenvector, so the magnitude of the spread.
So this is what we do, we take the scatter
matrix, compute eigenvalues and eigenvectors.
For big matrices, we do it of course
in code, like with this in Python.
Now that we have the eigenvectors, we can sort
them by eigenvalue to determine their importance.
And we are ready to reduce the dimension!
For this, we decide on how many
dimensions we want to reduce,
say D prime. So we take D’ eigenvectors and
put them into a matrix like this. (whisper: the
eigenvectors are D dimensional, since
they live in the original space)
And what we want then, is
to compute the new position
z in the new space of our data points, like this,
meaning that we take out each data point x and
multiply it with this matrix V of eigenvectors.
So we have x_i, a 1 timed
D matrix which is a vector,
multiplied with a D times d prime matrix.
What comes out is a 1 by D
prime matrix which is a vector,
so vectors in our new, reduced D prime dimensional
space. So because V projects our points x from a
higher dimensional space to a lower dimensional
space D prime, we call V the projection matrix.
What this projection matrix actually does
is it rotates the data, and maps it to
the new space with lower dimensionality
than the original one. And that was it!
And the best part is, we only
have to understand the idea once,
because the implementation of the algorithm is
already available in python with scikit-learn!
Let’s have a short look at how to use it!
This the one official scikit-learn examples,
where dimensionality reduction with PCA
is applied to the "iris dataset" containing
different flowers with 4 different features
to differentiate between them (for
example petal width and length).
But we humans, can not really
visualize the 4 dimensions,
until we do not reduce them
to at least 3 dimensions.
And this is luckily, exactly what this code does.
While the code might look dense, we will
now have a gentle introduction into it,
because you really have to know,
that PCA relevant lines are very few.
The first python lines are as always importing
specific packages like numpy for multidimensional
arrays, matplotlib pyplot for ploting and of
course sklearn for the Machine Learning part.
Sklearn is so kind to provide
us also with datasets.
So we load the iris data and
save it into the variable “iris”.
In Machine Learning, it is a custom to save the
data in a variable called X and the labels in y.
We initialize the PCA model by
using the class from scikit learn.
As a parameter, we specify the number
of principal components we want to keep,
so the dimensionality of our target
space, D prime which is now 3.
Basically, this line is where we
specify our intention to reduce
from the original dimensionality of 4, to
3. And the cool part about scikit-learn
is that you can exchange this line with many
other dimensionality reduction algorithms!
But now with PCA, we fit the model to the data
X, and we do not use or need any labels y, since
they are not of any use in the PCA algorithm,
which is a blind signal separation technique.
With the fitted model to our data, which has
internally done all complicated things for us,
like: centralized the data, computed the
scatter matrix, computed eigenvectors
and sorted them after the eigenvalues,
formed the projection matrix with them
so now it is ready to be applied on the
data to compute the new representation,
which is stored here again in X.
X is now three dimensional
and we are basically done.
We can use the rest of the code to make the cool
3D visualization that you see here at the side.
Is it really that easy? Yes, it is!
Now you have no excuse not to use
dimensionality reduction when needed.
Do not forget to like and subscribe!
Okay, bye.